[ Vocalizing ]
-All right, now, look.
Now here -- thank you.
-I hate this already.
-Thank you for playing
every game. I love you so much.
Here's how it works.
We're gonna have a number of
mystery objects
brought out to us.
In front of us.
Our job is to guess
what each one is.
The catch is that we have to
figure out only by touch alone.
-I hate this.
[ Light laughter ]
-Just by touch --
I know, me too.
All right, since I'm the host,
I'm going to go first. Let's get
in our first object here.
Please don't be a live thing or
a living thing or anything.
-Wait can I look? At his?
-Yes, you can look.
You can look if you want to.
[ Laughter ]
All right.
I have 30 seconds to identify
what this is.
-My poker face.
-All right, here we go.
Ah, oh, my gosh.
-I love it. Oh, my God.
♪♪
-Where is it?
Oh, ew.
[ Laughter ]
I don't like this.
-Look at your face.
He's turning red.
-I'm really gonna get
sick or something. Ew, gross.
-You got to guess.
You don't have much time.
Get in there with the fingers.
-Oh, it's a bagel.
It's a bagel
and something on it.
Locks and cream cheese?
[ Bell dinging ]
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Fishy fingers.
-Gross fishy fingers.
-Oh, my gosh.
All right, here you go.
-How did you do that?
-I don't know. All right,
whenever you're ready.
You have 30 seconds.
All right. Hold on.
[ Laughter ]
-Trying to read the audience.
Don't --
don't start with your face.
Stop it!
-Ew, no way, man.
No way! No way.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm not gonna touch it
if you do that.
-Whatever, man. You got to do
it. You got to guess it.
-Just stop.
Guys, I'm going to miss my time.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
What is that? What is this?
[ Light laughter ]
Is that a branch?
Is that an ice pick?
Is that an ice sculpture?
Is --
[ Light laughter ]
I don't know what -- it's ice.
-Kind of.
[ Buzz ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's a snowman.
-Oh.
-Snowman.
-Oh, man.
-It's clean over here.
-No.
-A snowman, it was close.
-I know, I was like --
couldn't tell what it was.
-All right, here we go.
-Okay, let's go.
[ Audience oohs ]
-Oh, my --
-Don't do that.
Don't do that.
Oh, my gosh. Seriously, I'm
going to freak out.
If it's moving or something,
I swear I'm going to freak out.
Don't you dare. Oh, my God.
Stop.
Aagh! I hate this game!
I hate it.
-It's so --
-I'm going to freak
out right now.
Don't do this to me, guys.
-It's --
-Aagh!
[ Audience screams ]
[ Laughter ]
-You have to touch it.
-Oh, my God. Whoo.
-Oh, my gosh.
Whoo, whoo, whoo.
Aagh!
[ Audience screams ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Is it a spider?
Is it a spider or something?
Is it a spider or a snake
or something ridiculous?
I hate it. 30 seconds, time.
-Here.
-No, I'm not gonna touch it!
-Pick it up.
-No! Oh, my gosh.
♪♪
-Touch it! Touch it!
Pick it up!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Bit me. It bit me, it bit me.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
It scared me. What is it?
What is it?
It bit me. Aagh!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, my gosh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't wanna --
-My shoes don't even
fit me anymore,
I don't know what happened.
-I don't want to play.
[ Light laughter ]
-You're such a good actor.
That scared me.
Oh, my gosh.
-Mommy, I don't wanna play.
I don't wanna play.
-This is the silliest
game I ever played.
-I don't want to play.
-Here we go. You're up.
Oh, my gosh.
We're upping the stakes.
They're upping the stakes.
Ooh.
-Okay.
-Oh, yeah, it's totally cool.
[ Light laughter ]
-Now I'm scared.
Now --
-No, it's totally cool.
It's totally cool.
Go in now and just touch it.
-Please stop.
[ Laughter ]
Please stop.
-I would just touch it. Oh --
-Shut up.
-It's normal. No, it's fine.
You can totally touch it.
-You're --
you're trying to trick me.
-No, no, no, no, no.
Just go right for it.
Just go right for it!
Aahh. [ Laughs ]
-Okay.
♪♪
[ Light laughter ]
Is it a plant?
-I don't know how
you're ever going to guess this.
Yeah, you got it easy.
-Sponge? A sponge?
-Yes.
-It's just a sponge?
-Yeah, that's what it
is, basically, right?
-It's more than that?
-It's a sponge in what?
[ Buzzer ]
-A sponge in a plant?
-Yeah a sponge in a toaster.
You got it easy.
-That was easy.
-I got a spider,
are you kidding me?
I was almost crying just now.
-Are we not done?
Are we not done?
-All right, here we go.
This is the final round.
-Can we be done?
-This is the final round.
Here we go. For this one,
we're going to get the same item
and the first person to guess it
wins, but there's going to be
a little extra competition for
this last one.
Please welcome from Jennifer's
movie "Second Act" her co-star
and also from "This Is Us,"
Milo Ventimiglia, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-How are you?
-Doing great.
How are you?
-Good to see you.
Good to see you.
Thank you for being here.
Milo, it's a very simple game.
Put your hand in the box and you
have to guess what it is, okay?
Here we go. I won't look.
-Hey, Milo.
-Did you have your diamonds on?
-I did.
-Are they missing now?
-Not yet.
[ Light laughter ]
Oh, wait. We all --
-Yeah, all right, we're all
going to do this. Ready?
-We're all going to do it?
-Yeah, we all gotta put our
hands in and guess what it is.
-You wanna -- agh!
-It could be anything!
The audience feels like it's
something scary.
-I'm gonna go in hard and fast.
Ready? Go.
-Yep.
-Go. Aagh!
[ Audience screams ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It's guacamole.
-Oh, it's guacamole, hey.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-With a garnish.
-With a garnish, of course.
Oh, my gosh.
Giant bowl of guac.
My thanks to Jennifer Lopez,
Milo Ventimiglia.
Their movie "Second Act" is
in theaters December 21st.
Stick around.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]